يبدو أن ما شهدناه خلال الـ 24 ساعة الماضية
كان أخطر
تهديد لقدرة بوتين على السلطة منذ
عقود. في هذه الساعة نعرف الكثير ولكن
من المهم الإشارة إلى أن هناك
الكثير غير معروف، على سبيل المثال ماذا
سيكون  مصير الرجل الجالس في
المقعد الخلفي لسيارة الدفع الرباعي هذه، إذا كان هناك أي شخص بريجوزي،
يهتف من قبل البعض عندما بدا أنه
يغادر روستوف في فجر
المدينة الواقعة جنوب روسيا، فقد احتلت قوات المرتزقة
للتو هذا الفيديو الذي تم التقاطه بعد
ساعات فقط من استدعاء
مرتزقته من هجومهم  تجاه
موسكو ووافقنا على صفقة توسطت فيها
حليفة روسيا بيلاروسيا،
ومن ثم ندرك المسؤولية الكاملة
عن حقيقة أن
الدم الروسي سيسفك من أحد الأطراف
ندير أرتالنا ونغادر في
الاتجاه المعاكس إلى
المعسكرات الميدانية حسب الخطة